I'm Walter, your lovebug,
and I'm here because
you are in love with Jessi.
What? No, I'm not.
I just like her more
than anyone
I've ever liked before ever.
-Shut up.
-Oh, baby boy.
If you didn't love her,
I wouldn't be here.
What do you mean?
From every Antony
And Cleopatra
To the Beyoncés and Jay-Zs
We've been stoking
The flames of passion
Since our climb down
Out of the trees
And we can help you
Seal the deal
But first
We got to know it's real
So tell me just one thing
-Do you feel the love?
-I… I think so.
Is there a warm
Electric tingle
From your nipples
To your chub?
-There is!
-You feel bubbles of elation
Like your heart farted
In the tub?
Yeah!
Or like you did
A huge line of blow?
Well, maybe
But I wouldn't know
Well, what I'm asking you
My friend
-Is do you feel the love?
-I think I feel the love
Do you long
To suck her eyeballs
And run naked
Through her hair
Well, of course!
Is there buzzing
In your skull
And lights are flashing?
All the time.
Could be you've gone insane
Or there's a tumour
Growing in your brain
-Wait, what?
-But more likely, boy
You're in the throes
Of passion
I think it's passion
You feel a cool
Refreshing blast
Like an Altoid up the ass
Oh, tell me, tell me, friend
-Do you feel the love?
-I feel the love!
Do you feel the love?
-In your nostrils?
-I feel it
-Or pumping in your hips?
-In your metatarsals?
-I feel it
In your big, fat lips
Do you feel the love?
I feel it
Yes, I feel the love
Holy shit.
I'm in love with Jessi.
Shut up!